hello and welcome to introduction to
responsible AI
this course will help you understand why
Google has put AI principles in place
identify the need for a responsible AI
practice within an organization
recognize that decisions made at all
stages of a project have an impact on
responsible AI
and recognize that organizations can
design AI to fit their own business
needs and values
many of us already have daily
interactions with artificial
intelligence or AI from predictions for
traffic and weather to recommendations
for TV shows you might like to watch
next
as AI becomes more common many
technologies that aren't AI enabled may
start to seem inadequate
now ai systems are enabling computers to
see understand and interact with the
world in ways that were unimaginable
just a decade ago
and these systems are developing at an
extraordinary pace
yet despite these remarkable
advancements AI is not infallible
developing responsible AI requires an
understanding of the possible issues
limitations or unintended consequences
technology is a reflection of what
exists in society so without good
practices AI May replicate existing
issues or bias and amplify them
but there isn't a universal definition
of responsible AI
nor is there a simple checklist or
formula that defines how responsible AI
practices should be implemented
instead organizations are developing
their own AI principles that reflect
their mission and values
while these principles are unique to
every organization if you look for
common themes you find a consistent set
of ideas across transparency fairness
accountability and privacy
at Google our approach to responsible AI
is rooted in a commitment to strive
towards AI That's built for everyone
that's accountable and safe
that respects privacy
and that is driven by scientific
excellence
we've developed our own AI principles
practices governance processes and tools
that together embody our values and
guide our approach to responsible AI
we've Incorporated responsibility by
Design into our products and even more
importantly our organization
like many companies we use our AI
principles as a framework to guide
responsible decision making
we all have a role to play in how
responsible AI is applied
whatever stage in the AI process you're
involved with from design to deployment
or application the decisions you make
have an impact
therefore it's important that you too
have a defined and repeatable process
for using AI responsibly
there's a common misconception with
artificial intelligence that machines
play the central decision-making role
in reality it's people who design and
build these machines and decide how
they're used
people are involved in each aspect of AI
development they collect or create the
data that the model is trained on
they control the deployments of the AI
and how it's applied in a given context
essentially human decisions are threaded
throughout our technology products and
every time a person makes a decision
they're actually making a choice based
on their own values
whether it's the decision to use
generative AI to solve a problem as
opposed to other methods or anywhere
throughout the machine learning
lifecycle that person introduces their
own sets of values
this means that every decision Point
requires consideration and evaluation to
ensure that choices have been made
responsibly from concept through
deployment and maintenance
because there's potential to impact many
areas of society not to mention people's
daily lives it's important to develop
these Technologies with ethics in mind
responsible AI doesn't mean to focus
only on the obviously controversial use
cases without responsible AI practices
even seemingly innocuous AI use cases or
those with good intent could still cause
ethical issues or unintended outcomes or
not be as beneficial as they could be
ethics and responsibility are important
not least because they represent the
right thing to do but also because they
can guide AI design to be more
beneficial for people's lives
at Google we've learned that building
responsibility into any AI deployment
makes better models and builds trust
with our customers and our customers
customers
if at any point that trust is broken we
run the risk of AI deployments being
stalled unsuccessful or at worst harmful
to stakeholders those products affect
this all fits into our belief at Google
that responsible AI equals successful AI
we make our products and business
decisions around AI through a series of
Assessments and reviews these instill
rigor and consistency in our approach
across product areas and geographies
these assessments and reviews begin with
ensuring that any project aligns with
our AI principles
while AI principles help ground a group
in shared commitments not everyone will
agree with every decision made about how
products should be designed responsibly
this is why it's important to develop
robust processes that people can trust
so even if they don't agree with the end
decision they trust the process that
drove the decision
in June 2018 we announced seven AI
principles to guide our work
these are concrete standards that
actively govern our research and product
development and affect our business
decisions
here's an overview of each one
AI should be socially beneficial
any project should take into account a
broad range of Social and economic
factors and will proceed only where we
believe that the overall likely benefits
substantially exceed the foreseeable
risks and downsides
two
AI should avoid creating or reinforcing
unfair bias
we seek to avoid unjust effects on
people
particularly those related to sensitive
characteristics such as race ethnicity
gender nationality income sexual
orientation ability and political or
religious belief
three AI should be built and tested for
safety
we will continue to develop and apply
strong Safety and Security practices to
avoid unintended results that create
risks of harm
4. AI should be accountable to people
we will Design AI systems that provide
appropriate opportunities for feedback
relevant explanations and appeal
five
AI should incorporate privacy design
principles
we will give opportunity for notice and
consent encourage architectures with
privacy safeguards and provide
appropriate transparency and control
over the use of data
6. AI should uphold high standards of
scientific excellence
we all work with a range of stakeholders
to promote thoughtful leadership in this
area drawing on scientifically rigorous
and multi-disciplinary approaches
and we will responsibly share our
knowledge by publishing educational
materials best practices and research
this enable more people to develop
useful AI applications
7. AI should be made available for uses
that Accord with these principles
many technologies have multiple uses so
will work to limit potentially harmful
or abusive applications
in addition to these seven principles
there are certain AI applications that
we will not pursue
we will not design or deploy AI in these
four application areas
technologies that cause or are likely to
cause overall harm
weapons or other Technologies whose
principal purpose or implementation is
to cause or directly facilitate injury
to people
technologies that gather or use
information for surveillance that
violates internationally accepted norms
and Technologies whose purpose
contravenes widely accepted principles
of international law and human rights
establishing principles was a starting
point rather than an end
what remains true is that our AI
principles rarely give us direct answers
to our questions on how to build our
products they don't and shouldn't allow
us to sidestep hard conversations
they are a foundation that establishes
what we stand for what we build and why
we build it and they are core to the
success of our Enterprise AI offerings